une ville éclatante avec ses décors de
carte postale
mais qui cache une certaine grisaille
plusieurs vitrines du centre ville de
saint jean des moindres des difficultés
économiques accentuée par la pandémie
sur doc wall street ce barbier
d'expérience constate le vide chaque
jour
les affaires de son salon tiennent à peu
de choses il a l'habitude d'accueillir
sur sa chaise des travailleurs du
pétrole mais les clients se font plus
rares agnès
locaux
à l'autre bout de la ville dans cette
usine de fabrication qui a pour
principal client l'industrie pétrolière
le bruit de la machinerie des zones
moins fort qu'avant
un soudeur était constamment déployés
sur les plateformes aujourd'hui les
sorties en mer sont moins nombreuses
pour les travailleurs c'est la tante et
l'incertitude
non
mais au large un espoir se profile la
pétrolière norvégienne et qui nord
attend l'approbation d'ottawa pour son
projet b du nord l'entreprise veut forer
un maximum de 60 puis à 500 km au large
de terre-neuve le but extraire de 300
millions à un milliard de baril sur 30
ans à compter de la fin de la décennie
ce qui pourrait représenter l'équivalent
de 7 ans de consommation de pétrole au
québec dans une province lourdement
endetté où le taux de chômage était le
plus élevé au canada le mois dernier le
projet b du nord est vu comme une bouée
de sauvetage des
terres-neuves n'a pas les moyens de son
passé insiste le premier ministre le
projet représenterait un minimum de
trois milliards et demi de dollars dans
les coffres de sa province et des
milliers d'emplois pendant sa durée de
vie
ce projet et extracôtier est présenté
comme le plus propre du canada son
empreinte carbone liées à l'extraction
serait une fraction de celle des sables
bitumineux
l'argument de vente convaincra-t-il
ottawa le gouvernement trudeau a
jusqu'au 6 mars pour donner le feu vert
au projet nous sommes sur la voie de la
réduction des émissions de gaz effet de
sable une décision déchirante pour le
ministre steven guilbeault qui a promis
d'imposer au plafond au secteur
pétrolier au canada et qui vient de
fixer des objectifs climatiques encore
plus ambitieux
un univers anormal à terre-neuve et
labrador avec des côtes dénudées doit
servir d'avertissement selon cette
militante dans un monde qu'on est en
crise climatique
on voit même ici à terre-neuve ya pas de
neige au début février le moment est
venu d'accélérer le virage et de
diversifier l'économie de la province
soit l on le voit ça fait des années et
des années qu en
économie pétrolière à terre-neuve et
c'est ce qu'on appelle un beau mais
baste on voit des grosses boules mais
aussi des super bateau très bas il faut
avoir d'autres sources économiques pour
ne pas dépendre seulement son pétrole
outre ses émissions carbone le projet b
du nord soulève d'autres craintes
environnementales
on retrouve des anémones de mer et ses
toiles de mer certains crustacés même à
plus de 1000 mètres sous la surface là
où on procédera aux forages la vie
marine est très riche rappel cette
scientifique il ya des champs de coraux
les éponges toutes sortes d'organismes
finalement qui non seulement créer une
biodiversité dans ces endroits là mais
parfois peuvent servir des rôles
beaucoup plus vaste notamment servir par
exemple de première à des poissons
lesquels poissons font l'objet de fiches
déchets de forage vibrations émissions
sonores risques de déversements
accidentels mais du nord pourrait
altérer des habitats ainsi que nuire aux
poissons aux mammifères marins et aux
oiseaux migrateurs malgré tout l'agencé
fédérale d'évaluation d'impact conclu
que le projet n'entraînera pas d'effets
environnementaux négatifs importants
difficile de l'affirmer avec certitude
selon cette scientifique puisque nos
connaissances sur les milieux profond
continue d'évoluer je pense qu'un peu à
l'image des grandes profondeurs c'est
plutôt parce que mes de dire qu'on
comprend l'ensemble qu'on comprend tous
les tenants de sang de tous les
noms dans cette province en contact si
étroit avec la nature ou le va et vient
des navires est intimement liée à
l'activité pétrolière où l'industrie est
incrusté dans le paysage le dilemme est
déchirant
corrie mise sur ce projet pour assurer
son avenir et celui de sa famille il
craint de devoir partir s'il ne se
réalisent pas
ici tous se sont interpellés
bobby jones
deux courants le économique l'autre
environnementale alimente ce débat très
sensible à terre neuve et labrador
la décision que s'apprête à prendre le
gouvernement trudeau posera
nécessairement des remous
[Musique]